there are some mcu opinions that go
decidedly against the grain
and make some truly decent points in
doing so
we're here to give those unpopular
points of view they're due
even if we bulk at them at first glance
the hulk's powers are very cool
especially their exponential nature
historically the hulk's degree of
strength is proportional with his anger
there are more than a few comic story
lines in which fighting makes him
angrier which makes him stronger
which makes his opponents escalate which
makes him even angrier
he's a perpetual motion machine of brute
force
with no apparent upper limit of ability
but the mcu consistently keeps him from
being the most powerful brawler of them
all
in the wake of infinity war one thinks
of thor before they think of hulk when
it comes to the best brawlers
it's not just that hulk's full strength
hasn't been unleashed in a while
though instead it's that he hasn't
gotten a major set piece since
thor ragnarok fortunately becoming
professor hulk doesn't mean he's retired
from being an unstoppable
golem of blind fury in fact it might
even drive that point home a little
better
banner put his brain in the other guy
and yet he's still
capable of being absolutely overwhelmed
with rage
that's how strong the hulk's powers are
get to it marvel
as it stands the hulk just doesn't feel
all that
incredible what comes to mind when you
think of scarlet witch's powers
red special effects telekinesis
illusions this vagueness is actually
pretty in line with her powers as
they've historically been depicted
stan lee and jack kirby kept her
abilities notoriously ill-defined to
allow for
creative interpretation this was a smart
storytelling move that also made scarlet
witch insanely
powerful what can she do exactly she's
created
entirely new realities erased thousands
of mutants powers and resurrected a
handful of dead people over the years
the problem is at this point she's
really more of a scarlet goddess than a
scarlet witch
but her powers might just stretch a bit
too far in the mcu
there's not much reason to believe they
don't so it's not too
far-fetched when you see people
comparing her to the likes of dr
strange thor and vision
after all we've seen her toss massive
machinery through the air
immerse the avengers in illusory
realities
and shatter the mind stone she was a
sloppier fighter in age of ultron true
but that almost makes her even more
impressive
if it only took a few years for her to
go from novice to
thanos thrasher where will she be in a
few more
you took everything from me
i don't even know who you are you will
when you think about character
development in the mcu
you think about the headliners such as
tony stark
t'challa and bruce banner the guardians
of the galaxy don't really come to mind
here
sure we love them but for what they are
the goofballs of the mcu one of them is
a pyromaniac raccoon after all
and his best friend is a tree somehow
this group of misfits
had the best character development in
the entire mcu
hear us out none of the guardians are
currently
anywhere near the place they started
star-lord is still a bit of a fool
but he's proven he can shoulder the
responsibility of caring for others
he's refused unlimited power when it
crossed a moral line
and he learned to reach out to those in
need gamora
and nebula overcame the iciness thanos
instilled in them
and found real sisterhood rocket with
yondu's help
confronted his own tendency to lash out
when he's feeling vulnerable
even drax has learned to care for others
even if he's still not great
at it the guardians don't clash in the
same old ways with every new installment
they face new challenges because they're
new people
it's some of the best writing the mcu
has to offer
and it's poised to get even better
deeper and stranger from here
[Music]
what do you remember about iron man 3
probably just one or two things
like the mandarin twist or the kid tony
spoils with hyper advanced tech
it's fallen through the cracks of the
mcu as much as any marvel movie can
it's not iron man 2 which was the go-to
choice for the
lesser mcu entry until thor the dark
world came along
and it's not iron man which has the
honor of having started the mcu in the
first place
it's just there some dislike the
mandarin twist
some think the actual villain is
forgettable most
everyone else hasn't thought about it in
years
and that's a real shame because iron man
3
is the best iron man movie of all
despite being a little weird
somehow this movie combines corporate
warfare
tony stark's chronic pain attacks and a
massive twist on a classic marvel
villain
and the destruction of nearly every iron
man suit
and makes it look easy we get some lo-fi
antics with tony stranded in rural
tennessee
and an action-packed climax in which
pepper potts
gets to deliver the final blow to say
nothing of the emotional drama between
the two
which hits new heights here who's the
hot mess now
still debatable probably tipping your
way a little bit why don't you dress
like this at home
sport bra the whole deal it's unlike any
other marvel movie
and it's likely that no one out there
loves every single thing about it
however it's probably a whole lot better
than you remember
and well worth revisiting age of ultron
is the other avengers movie you know
there's the first one
then infinity war then endgame
and you could make a real argument for
captain america civil war as
essentially an avengers movie as well
but
age of ultron well age of ultron is the
other one
with vision and evil ai and something
about quicksilver but not the cool one
from the x-men movies
it's not forgotten no mcu movie could be
but it's not beloved it has its
strengths
but they go tragically unsung watch it
again
remember the party scenes remember how
fun it was to watch the avengers hang
out
that sort of genuine camaraderie gave
way to
later relationships something
increasingly difficult to do
in the overstuffed mcu sure the razzle
dazzle heroics are fantastic
but we wouldn't care without the moments
of true connection underlying
every action scene moreover the ideas
that ultron introduces
the responsibilities of power whether
the avengers should play
offense or defense non-human
intelligence
have ended up forming the foundation of
the last few years of the mcu movies
no you're not going to revisit it as
often as the other avengers movies
but without it you wouldn't have some of
your favorite moments
movies and relationships someone who's
been playing an intricate game has made
pawns of us
once all these pieces are in position
tripoliate
you think you can find out what's coming
i do the hawkeye of the mcu is many
things
he's a dad a loner a top-tier archer
and occasionally a tattooed renegade in
the tokyo underworld
somehow this never quite adds up to much
this isn't to say he doesn't have his
fans
but how many people are out there buying
posters of clint barton specifically
do kids dress up as him in any major way
if he'd been the one to die on vormir
would there
be scores of fans on social media
decrying the death of their fave
signs point to no there's a good reason
for that
the clint barton of the comics is a
different character entirely
some runs make him insincere some lead
into his anti-authoritarian streak
and some take a uniquely low-key
approach to the character
matt fraction and david aha's celebrated
2012 hawkeye series blew the fans minds
by simply telling stories about what
hawkeye does on his days off while the
mcu character feels so flexible that he
ends up shapeless
hawkeye of the comic's flexibility
allows his
essential traits to rise to the top
whether he's in brooklyn
in a shield office or on a speeding
asteroid
he's scrappy wry and optimistic
that character has never quite shown up
on the big screen
though perhaps the fact that the disney
plus series is using the 2012 runs
iconography
is a good sign for the future all things
considered
dr strange is a solid movie it
introduces an intriguing new character
showcases his dizzy and cool corner of
the mcu
and culminates in an innovative showdown
with the big baddie
and yet comicbook.com has a point
when it says that dr strange plays like
several concepts of a movie at odds with
one another
listen we all like the part where he's
humbled by a hallucinatory trip through
time and space
we all laugh at wong's burgeoning
beyonce fandom
but when's the last time you reflected
upon the central romance
how about the character of cacillius
and frankly doesn't the magical martial
arts journey feel
a little rushed the parts of dr strange
that are strong
are so strong but even they can eclipse
the weaker and more disparate elements
of the film
it wants to introduce old lore tell a
story about a smug jerk
learning to do better shove in a romance
and convince us that strange masters
enough magic to go up against
long time users in what a few months
maybe a year or two at the most
superheroes encompass
many genres and require a certain amount
of suspension of disbelief
but even if you love dr strange you've
got to admit
it's a bit much could anyone have
predicted the waves
loki would make in the mcu fans fell in
love with the trickster god
on mass following his appearances in
thor
and the avengers in retrospect it's not
hard to understand
how this happened loki is a fascinating
character
torn between no fewer than three
opposing factions at any given time
he's a prince an outcast a god
a beloved brother and a chronic liar
plus he's played by tom hiddleston who
musters some truly shakespearean thunder
in every sly scene i'll not find you
brother
i'm not your brother i never was
at least that's the party line but not
everyone agrees
and quite honestly loki sucks
take a second to think about loki's
actions in the mcu
he betrays thor he works with aliens to
destroy
earth he betrays thor again he hides his
dad away in a nursing home
and takes the throne for himself yes
he also fights alongside his brother to
take down hella
and he dies trying to save the
asgardians from thanos
but that betrayal to heroism ratio isn't
pretty
moreover it's easy to think of him as
tragic
but really is he okay odin
and friega never told him he was a frost
giant
okay he's been raised in thor's shadow
that's tough stuff
it is however majorly enhanced by the
fact that he always had his family's
love
loki is a lot of fun to watch but he's
also pretty darn whiny
plus he took advantage of thor's love of
snakes
so i went to pick up the snake to admire
it and he transformed back into himself
and he was like yeah it's me
and he stabbed me we were eight at the
time
so you're a superhero you work with a
literal god
a man so strong he can keep a helicopter
from taking off with his bare hands
and a billionaire literally encased in
the most cutting-edge protection that
money can buy
you are a person a person
molded into a perfect assassin by
perfect assassin's school
granted but still a person no super
soldier serum
no suit of armor no godhood you
face down extraterrestrial monsters the
size of
whales with pistols taser bracelets and
your own two fists
the person who does that is about as
courageous as it gets
that person happens to be natasha
romanov
and you can make a strong case for her
as the bravest avenger of all
it's not just the fact that natasha does
these things however
it's that she doesn't have to the
country that trained her
is gone with her skills and after all
the hero work she's done
she could retire to a beach somewhere
but no
natasha chooses over and over again
to do the hard thing she's not bound by
ancient family ties
time displacement or public scrutiny
she does it because she knows she can be
of use and because she knows that her
own fear
doesn't outweigh the good she could do
if she conquers it
that's not just brave it's outright
noble
should the public trust superheroes it's
a question
marvel characters have been tackling for
decades
the mcu took a hard look at it in
captain america civil war
which pits tony stark against steve
rogers
in an ideological battle for the fate of
the avengers
tony scarred by ultron's rampage
supports un oversight of the team
while steve is skeptical it's a
fascinating conflict and a believable
one for steve to be mired within
after all he knows what it's like to be
allied with those in power
naturally he's more acquainted with its
downsides
it's his movie so it takes his ride and
yeah
he's got a point as john boyega
memorably noted
you don't want to wait for cap to
produce his permit before saving you
from a burning building
but maybe cap was dead wrong
the 117 countries who signed the sokovia
accords
aren't to be dismissed as fans who think
cap is on the wrong side of civil war
argue what if thor is in a forgiving
mood towards loki on the wrong day
what if nebula is brought in as
auxiliary help
and bloodily demonstrates her total lack
of interest in preserving bystanders
lives
some degree of oversight isn't a bad
idea
where you come to rest on the issue is
something you've got to work out for
yourself
but it's a topic worth tackling
regardless
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]